[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais pendant la pub mais oui ça fait des
victimes triple agression et sa fille au
sol quand ils auront peur de violences
partie par vous mon chéri
écoute moi bien si je gagne je gagne ta
chemise qui nous la donne tout de suite
si je perds je te le dis je t'envoie
pour un séjour magnifique
[Applaudissements]
bravo
on le retrouve ce soir dans la france a
un incroyable
oui on va voir les talents des
chroniqueurs dans un instant
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
qu'est ce qui te dérange location
gérance et c'est que sauf que pour
pourrait dans cette émission il faut
faire ce que vous faites
il faut assumer de dire ça j'aime ça
j'aime pas ses passes et tim tous les
jeux données sur la vie c'est pas le
chocolat
[Musique]
ap
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
tu vois quoi un peu du dominicain leur
boulot et avec new jersey nature
[Applaudissements]
bon
c'est le 97e match entre le psg et l'om
hervé alors si vraiment vous êtes des
spécialistes d'accord sur les chiffres
les deux équipes est ce que vous savez
qui a remporté le plus de confrontation
entre le psg et l'om je me suis pas
encore penché dessus je dirais marseille
mois historiquement ça y est vous paraît
alors c'est paris avec 42 victoires et
vingt et trente deux victoires pour
marseille qui connait rien terrasson
j'ai toujours dit ah ouais c'est un
chroniqueur me parler comme ça vient me
voir sur le plateau mais je vais
t'embrasser comme jamais je t'explique
que je vais galocher mais je te kiffe
mais de ouf
vient pourquoi pas on est trop potes on
se connaît trop bien je ne peux pas
galocher quelqu'un de ma famille elle
entendue non mais c'est vrai si tu crois
tu ta tête je suis prise en plus donc je
suis désolé avec tout le monde est pris
tout mais j'ai toujours avec moi une
doublure galoche
[Applaudissements]
camara
oh
c'est pas micro christine boulot et ceux
dits officiels à leur boulot
moi aussi j'ai toujours une doublure
galoche
[Applaudissements]
allez fun c'est quand
merci d'accueillir le champion données
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent à deux
balles de match pour la personne ça va
pas trop stressé non c'est bon tu l'as
déjà battu dominique elle tombe et c'est
une grande gueule
sache que tu auras des contrats
[Applaudissements]
ou tu me dis je reviens lundi mais si je
perds je perds tout ou bien tu me dis
non je repars avec ça je suis bien
content il va bien a dit qu'est ce que
tu dis je reviens hier
au delà en date
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les trois audi comme ça aurait été
tellement plus fort ses talons
et l'oseille les trois plus gros
salaires
patassé grade
j'ai par contre cagliari pas ils vont
venir
mais là il nous a fait nos jours michel
et castaldi a passé la nuit mais ce soir
les traits défense
[Applaudissements]
si les touchent la taxe touchera les
devis des meyrinois bénévoles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai mis les occasions qu'elle fautive
en championnat face
je sors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis encore plus pas de rival
la traviata vachiery bravo bravo